[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم في النقاش يمكنكم كالعاده
ان تتفاعل مع ما يقول الوضوء في البرنامج
على صفحتنا على فيسبوك وعلى صفحه البرنامج
على تويتر في النقاشه الرئيسيه من مدينه
الخطوط العريضه للاستراتيجيه العسكريه
وتحديدا في افريقيا واعلن انه سيتباعت في
الموضوع مع الشركاء لافارقه والحلفاء
والمنظمات الاقليميه قبل صياغه هذه
السياسه ما سيحتاج الى سته اشهر فرنسا
ستواصل تقديم الدعم الى الافارقه كالمكرام
الرئيس الفرنسي يدرك ضروري الطاعات مع راي
عام افريقي عارض فرنسا اكثر فاكثر
وبالتالي يريد التصدي الى القوه المنافسه
والتي تسعى الى ضرب النفوذ الفرنسيه عبر
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وفي وسائل
الاعلام مثل ما فعلت موسكو وبالتالي مساله
النفوذ ستصبح قضيه استراتيجيه للدفاع في
فرنسا التي لن تضل تلعب دور المتفرج امام
الترويج الاخبار الكاذبه والمضلله قال
مكروه الى اي ستنجح فرنسا في بسط نفودها
في القاره السمراء من يتحمل مسئوليه
انتشار قوى اخرى منافسه في افريقيا مثل
روسيا وتركيا وغيرها من الدول الاخرى ماذا
بقي اصلا من النفوذ الفرنسي في القاره
الافريقيه سعيد بان يناقش الموضوع وما اي
من القاهره هبه البشبيشي ويستدت الدراسات
الافريقيه في جامعه القاهره سعيد بان يكون
معي من باريس بسبب اضراب وسائل النقل خطار
ابو دياب للمره الاولى عبر سكايب من منزلي
واستاد العلاقات الدوليه همم ومعنى ايضا
من باريس دائما بسبب الاضراب دمبا محمد
ذكوري وباحث في الشؤون الافريقيه
والاجتماعيه اهلا وسهلا بكم قبل ان نبدا
نستمع الى ما قاله مكروه
موجود اليوم اكثر من امس للمصالح الحيويه
لفرنسا بعض اوروبي
ولذلك فان قواتنا النوويه تساهم من خلال
وجودها في امن فرنسا واوروبا دعونا نحرص
على ان لا ننسى ان فرنسا لديها رجع
النواوي قررت بالتشاور مع شركائنا انهاء
عمليه برخان في منطقه الساحل
دعمنا سيستمر ولكن وفقا للمبادئ الجديده
التي تم تحديدها معهم
هبدا معك يا هبه بشبيشي من القاهره بلدي
بقي من النفوذ الفرنسي في القاره
الافريقيه
خليني ابدا مع حضرتك بمقوله لاحد الخبراء
الفرنسيين في ليفاجارو ال ان فرنسا اذا
تدخلت في الشان الافريقي فهي متهمه واذا
انسحبت من الشان الافريقي فهي ايضا متهمه
اذا همم فرنسا هي في حاله اتهام طوال
الوقت اذا انسحبت اذا وجدت اذا تفاعلت همم
اعتقد ان ده في حد ذاته نفوز اا وجود
فرنسا على الساحه لافريقيه باتصور ان هو
يعني همم نوعا ما امر مسلم به امر مطلق
موجود همم لكن يختلف هذا الوجود ويتراوح
ما بين القوه وما بين التراجع همم اما انه
وجود ثقافي وفكري اما انه وجود تاريخي كان
استعمار فرنسي همم اما الان فنحنا نتحدث
عن الوجود العسكري همم اذا كنت حضرتك تقصد
بالنفوذ التواجد العسكري الحقيقي لفرنسا
يعني اعتقد ان فرنسا ما زالت موجوده في
يعني همم
الوجود العسكري اللي هو اا ليه بقوات
الوطنيه او الاستراتيجيه الجديده التي
بدات تتبعها فرنسا همم وفكره الانتقال من
مجرد همم مواجهات حقيقيه بين القوات
الفرنسيه والتجمعات الاسلاميه المسلحه الى
تدريب العناصر الوطنيه سواء في الجيش او
الشرطه
لاحداث الموجهه الوطنيه اللي احنا بنتكلم
عنها او بنتحدث عنها للدول الافريقيه همم
فكره النفوذ اا ما اقدرش اقول ان نفوز
الفرنسي همم مش موجود وما اقدرش اقوله ان
تراجع بالحد اللي نقدر ننسى في وجود فرنسا
لكن هو ما زال موجود على المستوى الثقافي
على المستوى همم الدعم اللوجيسي على مستوى
اا تبادل الخبره العسكريه زي ما قلت
لحضرتك همم فاكر التغير الاستراتيجيه بقى
هو ده اللي ممكن يكون المقصود به فكره
التغير الحقيقي في الوجود الفرنسي همم
تسعه رقع او دقها اللي متواجد عليها قوات
الحقيقه غير الفرنسيه همم مش ده اساس اللي
انا باقيم عليه عمليه التواجد الحقيقه
يعني همم ممكن تكون فرنسا مش موجوده في
منطقه شرق افريقيا لكن ما اقدرش اقول ان
فرنسا لو وجود لها في الشرق افريقيا
الثقافه الفرنسيه موجوده التاريخ الفرنسي
موجود ما يسمى بالمدرسه الكلاسيكيه
الفرنسيه التي درست افريقيا موجوده لكن
همم التواجد العسكري ليس هو المعيار
الاساسي بالنسبه لي انا على الاقل في
تقييم مساله النفوس طيب خطير ابو دياب حسب
قراءتك انت للمشهد لماذا كل هذه
الانتقادات
للوجود الفرنسي في افريقيا هل هناك من حرض
على ذلك
احييك يا استاذ توفيق احيي فريق العمل في
فرنسا
القسم العربي
والمحاولين الكرام وكل من يشاهدنا ويتبعنا
يعني هذه هي لعبه التنافس الدولي ولا يدوم
اي نفود مثل ما كان بشكل دائم هذه هي ايضا
قاعده التاريخ فرنسا كانت تصنع الرؤساء
وتصنع
الاحداث ولها تاثير كبير وايام الحرب
البارده كان هناك تقاسهم هناك فرنسا
وبريطانيا ورعايه امريكيه ولكن كان هناك
ايضا روسيا وبعد اذن بعد نهايه الحرب
البارده اتت الصين والان تاتي روسيا من
جديد ومع قوى اقليميه اخرى اذا هي ساحه
مفتوحه حتى بالنسبه للقوه الاوروبيه
الاخرى التحريض ضد فرنسا هو منتظم ولكنه
ايضا ناتج عن اخطاء في المقاربه الفرنسيه
فرنسا ااه ضحت كثيرا او لسماعتها من خلال
عمليات عسكريه منذ سربال الى بركان اي منذ
2013 الى اليوم وكان ربما هناك اخطاء في
المقاربه وعدم القدره عند الدول الوطنيه
المشكله ان هذه الدول بعد الاستقلال لم
تتمكن من ان تكون على مستوى الدول الفاعله
وربما هنا الانتقاد لفرنسا في عدم
مساعدتها في اللحظه المناسبه لتبول هذه
المكانه او بتهتم فرنسا بالراي العام امس
ما لفت نظري في كلام الرئيس مكروه انه
سيخوض المواجهه الرقميه في زمن الوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي هو تاخر كثيرا لان
الغير وربما قوه خارجيه منافسه وفرنسا
تقصد هنا روسيا حرضت من خلال وسائل
التواصل معي الناس لكن كان هناك الميدان
الخصب لذلك نظرا
لتاريخ فرنسا كقوه استعماريه سابقه لصعود
ايضا الحركات الاسلاميه وعلينا الا نخفف
من اثر ذلك وبعد اذن على رغبه
الكوليرالات او الكابتان من جديد عسكر من
جديد وهم في سده الحكم يسعون للبقاء من
اجل البقاء من دون الانتباه لمصالحهم
الوطنيه كل ذلك اذا ادى لخسائر فرنسيه
الان يحاول مكروه الحد من الاضرار عبر
صاحب النهائي لعمليه برخان اعاده تقييم
الوجود العسكري الفرنسي او النفوذ الفرنسي
بالطبع لا يقتصر على العمل العسكري والحرب
ضد الارهاب هو ثقافي اقتصادي متجددر
وبالطبع اذا لم تحسن فرنسا التخاطب مع
الجيل الجديد من الافارقه عند ابن معركتها
ستكون خاسره طيب دم محمد بكري اريد ان
اسالك سؤال واضح يعني كنت حاذرا عندما كان
جاك شيراك في باماكو عام 2008 ورايته
لاستقبال الذي حضي به الرئيس في قمه فرنسا
في افريقيا حتى على طول الشارع من المطار
باماكو حتى قاعه الصداقه الصينيه التي
نظمت فيها تلك القمه في باماكو ما الذي
جعل الوضع يتغير والرؤيه تغير كليا هل مثل
ما يلمح او يقول خطر ابو دياب فرنسا تتحمل
مسؤوليه في ذلك وهو ان التاريخ هو هكذا
يعني يوما اليك ويوم عليك ام ان هناك
من حرك هذا الامر داخليا حتى في مالي
شكرا للاستضافه همم بدايه همم
اقول جوابا على سؤالك السيد توفيق مجاهد
اما يجب علينا ان نفرق بين امرين مهمين
يجب علينا ان نفرق بين
حمالات همم
عضلات معاديه جدا فرنسا كدوله
وتحضاره وقت قوه اقتصاديه السادسه
واا
المطالب التي
يطلبها اكثر من سكان دول
الساحل والصحراء يعني عندما نقول من هنا
ليست هناك همم حاسيس
معاذ ضد فرنسا دوله هذا لا يوجد همم اعتقد
ان الثقافه الفرنسيه
والحضاره الفرنسيه موجوده يعني بشكل مكثف
في الدول الصح الصحراء وحتى في المغرب
العربي انسحب عليه بصفه عامه اذا همم
فرنسا لها وجود قانون جدا يعني في في
ثقافه الافارقه ولكن المشكله همم ان
القضيه هي قضيه السياسه قضيه الاستراتيجيه
يعني شتان ما بين
مؤاداه دوله كدوله ومؤادادات استراتيجيه
وخطه عمل كاستراتيجيه وخطه عمل يعني هناك
رفض
الاستراتيجيه السياسيه
الفرنسيه نبك كثير من الافارقه في دول
الساحل الصحراء انت تطلقت الى زياره رئيس
جاكي الشراك في عام 2008 ومن كان النبي
على ذلك ايضا زياره في عام 2013 في الي
دوله
في هذا الجو يعني الوجوب الفرنسي
همم
ان تكون لها نتائج السلبيه همم مذكر ان
الوجود الفرنسي بدا نتيجه
الانعكاسات السلبيه التي حدثت يعني في
ليبيا في الثوره الليبيه يعني هي قضيه
الجنس السياسيه التي انعكست على دوله
ماليزيه
فرنسا عندما تدخلت العسكريه للمره الاولى
بمطالبه الحكومه الانتقاليه الماليه انا
ذاكر
العسكري الفرنسي كان سبب
وقوف تقدم
الارهابيين والقوات والجماعات المسلحه زي
المنبه يستطيع ان يقول ان تدخل العسكري
الفرنسي في عام 2013 كان تبخلا يعني
ايجابيا وتدخل الموافقها ولكن بعد ذلك
بفتره حصل هناك
تغيرات في
الاكسجين بقى اكثر من 2500 جندي او عسكري
فرنسي في منطقه الساحل والصحراء فلم نرى
نتائج
فالقوات
الارهابيه همم اصبحت يعني تقتل الاف مقبل
مئات اصلا مئات من الناس واصبحت يعني همم
تحرك الكره بكاملها
فالشعب او راوي العام بدا يسال نفسه ايوه
الوجود الفرنسي فمن هنا خصله هناك اكثر
بالنسبه هذا الترب وهو محمد السؤال ما
الذي حدث بالنسبه
ما حصل يعني في ميدان الحرب يعني حيث لم
تكن هناك نتائج ايجابيه كما كما منتظره
طيب هبه دائما نعود الى نفس النقطه ان
نحمل فرنسا مسؤوليه ما حصل على الارض
وانما الامر يتعلق بمكافحه جماعات همم
جهاديه همم ت بشكل مختلف وفي كل العسكريين
يعني يجمعون على القول من الصعب جدا
مواجهه هكذا جماعات وراينا ذلك في الماضي
حتى مع دول اخرى
همم
اتكلم مع حضرتك ولو يعني اعمل فكره سريعه
عن الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه الجديده الحقيقه
همم يعني الكلام كله بيدور حول النفوذ
الفرنسي لا النهارده انا بتكلم عن
استراتيجيه عسكريه اا جديده لفرنسا وفرنسا
قوه اوروبيه كبيره همم عندها قوه عسكريه
وتقدم تكنولوجيا عالي همم نقدر نقول ان
السبب الحقيقي في تغير الاستراتيجي
الفرنسيه الحقيقه ما كانتش الدول
الافريقيه الحقيقه كانت الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه خلينا نحطه الامور في نصابها
لان التسع سنوات من الحرب تسع سنوات من
الوجود الفرنسي عمليات همم متعاقبه تكون
وتدخل دول مختلفه وتدخل قوه دوليه كبيره
الحقيقه اللي ساهم مباشره وكان الفعل
الرئيسي في تغير الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه
عسكريه ثم دخل افريقيا كانت الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اولا انا عندي حرب اعتمدت فيها
اوكرانيا بالكامل او زي لان الدول
الاوروبيه اعتمدت بالكامل على الناتو وعلى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ثم ااا كان
هناك زي يعني قلاقل ما بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وعتاب وحديث عن ان
الناتج اللي المحلي الاجمالي للدول
الاوروبيه كبير ولماذا لا تساهم في قوات
الناتو بناتج اكبر او بمساهمه فاعله اكبر
الحقيقه همم الحديث عن
الحديث عن همم الو تفضلي الحديث عن همم
تحول استراتيجيه الفرنسيه عن القوه
النوويه الفرنسيه وانها قوه ردى اا هائله
موجوده في اوروبا وتحت ابره الاستخدام
الاوروبي ولا مانع ولكنها لن تستخدم اذا
ما قامت روسيا بيه استخدام النووي الحقيقه
التصريح ده في منتهى الاهميه وكان لابد من
الالتفات اليه ايضا تحدث عن الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه ذات العمليات عاليه الكثافه هذا
التعبير في حد ذاته هو تعبير موجه ل- اا
الدول الاوروبيه ولا الاتحاد الاوروبي
وليس مواجهه لافريقيا يعني العمليه
العسكريه في افريقيا هي عمليه غيره عاليه
الكثافه لان احنا ممكن جيوش وطنيه تقوم
بالمواجهه مع الجماعات المسلحه لانها مهما
كانت هي في اطار الجماعه المسلحه لا تملك
طيران لا تملك دبابات لا تملك مقومات
الجيش اذا ما تدرب الجيش الوطني في الدول
افريقيه تدريب حقيقي اعتقد ان عنده القدره
على المواجهه مع الجماعات المسلحه ده شك
شق الاخر ان حديث مكروم كان عن تغيير
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه ال- الفرنسيه في
اوروبا بالكامل وانها ستكون دوله توازنات
اقليميه دوله توازن اقليمي عسكري يا فندم
اوروبي وليس افريقي الحديث عن الوجود في
افريقيا يعني منذ ما اختفت العسكريه
الفرنسيه من افريقيا منذ متى اختفت لن
تختفي هي فكره تخفيف وطات الوجود العسكري
في افريقيا لا تعني ابدا انتهاء العمليه
العسكريه في افريقيا ايضا التحرك العسكري
الموازي لفرنسا داخل التكتل الاوروبي
بالمواجهه مع الناتو الحقيقه هو ده كان
مستهدف وده اللي انا قريته من خلال
سحب القوات الفرنسيه بالتزامن مع قيام
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا كان
فبراير 20 20 20 22 هو الفيصل وهو الحكم
يا فندم تدخلت روسيا في اوكرانيا وانسحبت
فرنسا مباشره من مالي وبالتالي هذه لعبه
الشطرنج سحب من هنا ووضع هنا الحقيقه
بالاساس ليس الدافع هنا الدول الافريقيه
ولكن انا بتصور بصوره كبيره جدا الدافع هو
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ظهور قوه
اوروبيه قويه عسكريه تقدر تدافع عن
الاتحاد الاوروبي وعن الكائنات الاوروبيه
ضد الاعتداء الروسي اذا ما تطور عن ذلك
اصبح مهم
يا اخي اولا
علينا ان نحدد ان مكروه عندما تكلم في
تولومب الامس
تحدث عن ما يسمىه المجله الاستراتيجيه
الوطنيه اي العقيده الاستراتيجيه لفرنسا
من الان الى العام 2030 هو تحدث بشكل عام
كما تكلمت الدكتوره هبه عن انه نتيجه
تدهور الوضع الدولي كيف ستكون فرنسا كيف
ستتحمل مسؤولياتها ولكنه كان متواضعا وضع
ذلك في اطار اوروبي وفي اطار اطلسي ومن
دون ان يمنع ذلك فرنسا من القيام
بسياساتها الخاصه من اصل الخطاب من حوالي
40 دقيقه كان هناك حوالي يعني اربع دقائق
بشكل خاص عن القاره الافريقيه لانه وعد
انه خلال سته اشهر
سيعلن صياغه استراتيجيه فرنسيه جديده في
افريقيا ما نفهمه الان ان مساله برخان نعم
ربما اوكرانيا صرعت بكل هذا لكن كان السيف
قد سبق العزل مجرد وصول
العسكريين الى الحكم في باماكو هم الذين
طلبوا من فرنسا ان تترك مالي واليوم يتكرر
نفس المشهد في بوركينا فاسو فرنسا عندما
لا يطلب منها لن تبقى وهذا كان واضحا وهذا
الجديد في كلام مكروه فرنسا ستتعاون مع
القوه الوطنيه هناك ان كان في النجر في
تشاد هو غيرها من اجل استكمال المعركه ضد
الارهاب لكن ليس من خلال سكنات ثابته
ومراكز تجمع او وجود دائم او اكبر عمليه
فرنسيه خارجيه كما كانت عمليه بل سيكون
ذلك عبر القوات الخاصه عبر المعلومات وعبر
العمل المشترك تحت قياده القوات الوطنيه
هذا هو شيء جديد في الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه
اي المزيد من الثقه باللاعب الافريقي
المزيد من الحوار مع الشباب الافريقي من
اجل
ليس لا يمكن ان يتم نسيان صوره الدوله
الاستعماريه السابقه بسهوله لكن التاريخ
لا يمكن ان يقف عند محطات معينه فرنسا همم
تحاول من خلال اعاده الصياغه اعطاء اهميه
للمساله الافريقيه ليس من اجل افريقيا
لوحدها لكن من اجل فرنسا واوروبا ايضا
لانه اذا نظرنا الى خريطه هذا التخبط في
العالم والى الصراعات الجيول السياسيه
الجديده التي يمكن ان ترتسم اذا تكلمنا عن
اهم بعد استراتيجي اربعه هو موجود في
افريقيا موجود في البحر الابيض المتوسط
اذا هو موجود في الجنوب الفرنسيه ومن هنا
فرنسا ستعطي عنايه كبيره
لاعاده
الترتيب استراتيجياتها وسياساتها ليس فقط
في جنوب افريقيا بل في المتوسط في الشرق
الاوسط ما سماه ميكروب ان تكون فرنسا دوله
تقود تحالفات مع اليونان واعطى مثلا
اليونان اعطى ركز كثيرا على دوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده وكل هذا يدخل ضمن السياق
فرنسي عام
لمواجهه تحديات كبيره في هذا العقد من
الزمن طيب ده انت كنت رايت كمان تريد
تتفاعل مع هبه اتفضل
همم كنت اريد ان اكون همم طبعا لا اتفقنا
الكرام يعني
ولهذا استلف هناك لو تتفق معهم يعني هسه
يعني خلاص ما فيش نقاش يعني ههه
اولا همم هناك نقطه يعني مهمه بالنسبه لي
لا يمكن ان نلقى ان نلقي النوم على فرنسا
لا يعني همم اللون همم يعني مهم يبقى ايضا
على الافارقه انفسهم يعني مثلا مشكله دول
افريقيا الساحل والصحراء يعني هو مشكله
اكمل في نقطتين مهمتين نقطه الاولى سوء
الاداره همم الحكومات المتعاقبه التي
رايناها مثلا في دوله مالي كانت حكومات
فاشله همم متساوي الفساد المالي التي الذي
يغضب على كثير من موضوع الساحل والصحراء
همم الافارقه انفسهم لا هي المسؤوليه في
تدهور المجتمع الامنيه الموجوده في منطقه
الساحل والصحراء لماذا قلت يعني لا اتفق
مع الضيفين ال ال
النقطه الاولى
هي اا الدايت فيلم كريمان اشار الى ان
التبهر
العالمي خاصه
ارض في بين روسيا واوكرانيا يعني لها دور
في قضيه همم منطقه الساحل والصحراء يعني
اريد ان يشير ان تراجع الشعبي العسكريه
الفرنسيه لدى الافارقه كانت موجوده قبل
الحرب همم
حرب الاوكرانيه روسيه في في قضيه الساحل
والصحراء يعني
يجيب العسكريين الفرنسي كانت يعني ضعيف
جدا ووضع الراي العام الافريقيه قبل شهور
كثيره من همم قبل الحرب العروس روسيا
والاكراميه كثيره
هي همم
الضيف دكتور اعشاب لان هناك يعني تنافس
طبعا انا لا انكر ان هناك تنافس بين روسيا
وفرنسا ولكن اا هذا التنافس
يجب ان نفهم ان الافارقه هم اصحاب هم يعني
اصحاب المجال لا يمكن ان نقول مثلا روسيا
او فرنسا كمان
اقتصاديا وعسكريا تستطيعين ان تفعل يعني
في المنطقه
اصحاب
القضيه والقضيه في هذا في هذا الشهر يعني
يعني طبعا لا خلاف على ان الافارقه هم
الفعل الرئيسي في الازمه الافريقيه
الفرنسيه انا فقط اتحدث عن
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الفرنسيه الجديده
التي تحدث عنها مكروه انا امام خطاب مقرون
امام توجه جديد للدوله الفرنسيه العملاقه
الكبيره اللي كانت موجوده لسنوات طويله في
افريقيا ولم تحدث شيء على ارض الواقع في
تغيير التواجد الاسلامي العسكري او المسلح
لكن نحن نتحدث عن ما قاله مكرونه
لا يوجد هناك يعني الله يسمى بالتواجد
بالحركات الاسلاميه
في احدى تصريحاته بان يعني حركات اسلاميه
التي تحرك ضد فرنسا هذا ليس صحيح يعني
الافارقه او عند الراي العام الافريقي هنا
توقع يعني من له بسيط انت الفتره التي
يعني التي كان فيها شعب يعني نايم او في
سباتها وفي ثباتها عفوا الان هناك هكذا
عند الافارقه يعني هناك يعني
لحظه من فضلك الا يوجد تنظيم القاعده الا
يوجد تنظيم انصار السنه لا يوجد همم
تنظمات حرام هل هذه هل هذه التنظيمات التي
ذكرتها بالاسم ليست تنظيمات اسلاميه يعني
خلينا نتحدث عن اشياء بعينها من فضلك وهل
هذه تنظيمات لا توجد في مالي
تنزيلات ارهابيه يعني النمس التنظمات
ارهابيه من عبقه القاعده يا فندم تحت لواء
القاعده التي تتحدث عن نفسها انها نظام
اسلامي
من العنف سبيلا لاقرار دوافعه واهدافه
ووجوده
يعني هناك ربما حركات للاسلام السياسي لا
علاقه لها بهذا الشان حسب ما افهم وهناك
وهناك الان دور لرجال دين في دعم همم
العسكريين الموجودين في الحكم
انت انت بنفسك يعني تفرقت الى كلمه
الحركات الاسلاميه ماذا تقصد بذلك نعم
القصد هو من يتبع الاسلام السياسي ليس
القصد هو ال- ال- الدين الاسلامي او او
المسلمون
يعني تصريح مكروه قلبي ان الحركات
الاسلاميه هي التي جدا في فرنسا بالنسبه
لمروه بالنسبه لميكروه هو يعتبر ان
التحريض ياتي بالطبع يعني هناك قاعده
معينه علينا ان ننكر القواعد المسمى
جهاديه ان كانت تتبع
لقاعده في المغرب الاسلامي او لتنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه
لكن هناك ايضا لا انا اقر معك هناك ايضا
راي عام افريقي مستقل راي عام من الشباب
انا ركز على الشباب هناك جيل يعتبر ان كل
اخطاء الدنيا اتيه من المستعمل السابق وان
الفكر ان الفشل العسكري لهذا المستعمر
السابق في الحرب ضد الارهاب هو السبب
للمزيد من التحريض لكن اذا تواعدنا بدقه
في هذا الموضوع
المساله في ماله هناك مساله الطوارق هناك
حركات متمرده غير الحركات الارهابيه هناك
ما اسميتهم تجار نظارات والعصابات اذا
هناك عنف متعدد الابعاد وكل هذا يزيد من
الصعوبات هناك مناطق حتى اليوم خارج عن
سلطه الدوله هل ستنجح فاجنر مع العسكريين
في مالي اكثر من ما نجحت في فرنسا نجحت
فرنسا سنرى المستقبل بجنير في السودان
تصرخ الذهب الان من السودانيين همم يعني
الان لا اقول ان فرنسا كانت بريئه وكانت
ذلك الملاك في افريقيا لكن المساله هي كيف
يستعيد الافارقه العمل في بلادهم او
السيطره على ثروات بلادهم اداره شؤون
بلادهم انا اؤيدك سدام بقى المساله هي بيت
الافارقه فرنسا يمكن ان اسمع صوت وصوره
يعني احنا اخذنا النقاش بعد اذنكم احنا
اخذنا النقاش لمرحله عاطفيه الدفاع عن
الاسلام انا ابدا انا مسلمه ولا اهاجم
الاسلام من قريب او من بعيد نحن نتحدث عن
مصطلح سياسي سياسي في الشؤون العسكريه
يتخذ من الجماعات الاسلاميه التي تتخذ من
الاسلام ستار لاقرار دوافعها العدوانيه
والارهابيه سميها كما شئت لكن انا اتحدث
بالعلم بمدرسته في العلوم السياسيه يوجد
ما يسمى بالجماعات الاسلاميه
المسلحه يا فندم انا لا اتحدث عن العواطف
انا هنا للحديث في العلم الحديث عن جماعات
حقيقه تتخذ من الاسلام ستار موجوده في
مالي اسمها بالاسم سميتها لسيادتك بوكه
حرام ويا جماعه انصار الاسلام ويا جماعه
همم الدواعش اللي ظهره فيه مالك وجماعه
تحت لواء القاعده يعني ما كل هذا مالي
وحدها في اكثر من 17 تنظيم لا اذكرهم
بالاسم لكن انا دي دراسات يا فندم احنا
نتعدل على العلم عاطف وحضرتك مش مواطل لو
مش مواد كان للدفاع عن الجماعات الاسلاميه
الارهابيه فهتشيلي الاسلاميه وتقول
الارهابيه حضرتك بتعمل ايه ده حقيقه يا
فندم وعلم بندرسه واول مواجهه في افريقيا
هي مواجهه الجماعات المسلحه الاسلاميه
حضرتك عدت لي الجماعات الارهابيه اللي
موجوده في افريقيا غير عبائه الاسلام هات
لي جماعه من المتطرفين موجوده في اي دوله
في افريقيا خارج عباءه الجماعات الاسلاميه
التي تقول نحن نحكم بامر الله وبشرع الله
اتحدث عنكم حرام من قامك بخطف الفتيات في
نيجيريا بالقيام بعمليات مسلحه في عمق ال-
ال- النيجيري والمالي والنيجر والشد ما
هذا يعني فكره اختطاف فتيات الاعتداء على
الكنائس ذبح المسيحيين انت لا تعلم ما
يحدث في بلدك يا فندم ولا هذه الاخبار
كذابه
باحترام لك يعني يجب عليك ان تراجعي دروسك
يعني السياسيه ههه
[موسيقى]
شغل يا فندم بقى لي في اكثر من 20 سنه
حضرتك رجعه ال- ال- الاشكاليه اللي عندك
في انك تواجه لفظ الاسلام احنا مش في
عواطف احنا بنواجه حقيقه مؤكده
يا استاذ توفيق تدخل هناك يمين متطرف في
اوروبا يتخذ من المسيحيه ستار اسمعني من
فضلك هناك يمين متطرف في اوروبا يتخذ من
المسيحيه ستار وعمليات مسلحه هل مستبعد ان
انا اكون مسيحيه جنب كلمه اليمين المتطرف
طبعا لا في العلوم السياسيه ده امر
طبعا يلا بينا
ههه
اقول لك يعني بكل يعني انحياديه انا انا
ليست لدي خطه تحليليه او تابعه لمنظمه انا
حر يعني باحث حر اعرف الميدان جيدا يعني
ليس كما ذكرت يعني في منطقه الساحل
والصحراء المشكله تكمل من ثلاث مجالات
المجال الاول عندما حركات ارهابيه انا
مسميها ارهابيه يعني من حركه القائده ومن
حركه الدايش الارهابيه الارهابيه موجوده
انا لو قلت ذلك يعني المجال الثاني هناك
حركات حركات يعني جماعات مسلحه التي
ليست حركات حركات اسلاميه
وبالتالي سكايب يعاني معك فخليك ما تتحرك
يعني ما تنفعل بس
هبه هي طبعا مميزه لان هي عبر القمر
الصناعي بس انت عبر سكايب اهدا شويه لانه
سكايب خلاص ما قدر يتبعك يعني تفضل
في صورتك
التي يعني تقوم همم المخدرات يعني هي
موجوده معروفه لا احد يمكن هذا
والاخير انها حركاتنا الانسانيه يعني
حركاته
الجديد الحقيقه في العلوم السياسيه
يعني 10% شمال
مملكه الطوارئ في هذه المنطقه من العالم
طيب ذنبه دبه لمعرفه شويه لشمال مالي يعني
هل من السهوله بمكان
هتتنقل بين كيدال وتومبكتو على سبيل
المثال هل من السهوله بمكان ان تتنقل بين
باماكو وشمال البلاد بهذه السهوله الا
يوجد قطاع طرق على سبيل المثال التي توجد
مشاكل هل الحافلات لا تتعرض الى
الاعتداءات كل مره تقترب من الشمال
طبعا ليس من الامر يسهل الامر الهين يعني
الظروف الامنيه في الشمال المالي يعني وفي
سحل وصلات من الصحراء بصفه عامه جروب صعبه
جدا وانا بكل شفافيه لانكر ان دوله مالي
حاليا يعني رغم
تقدمها في في شراء الاسلحه
والمؤيدات العسكريه هي حاليا ليست قادره
امنيا على الدوله بكاملها هذه الحقيقه
يعني انت كمواطن عادي يمكنك ان تزورك
بسهوله
طبعا ليس هذا الذي ذكرته يعني ليس من
السهل انزلها وانا طبعا قريبا سازور مالي
اود كنت اود يعني ان ازور مدينه تمبكتو من
اجل البحث الجامي على المخطوطات الطرمبك 2
التاريخيه ولكن لا استطيع الذهاب يعني
لاسباب امنيه طبعا يعني كمواطن مالي ليس
من الامر سهل زياره شمال مالي
فالتحدي الامني يبقى تحديا كبيرا جدا
يعني بعد اذن حضرتك
عايزه اعمل تداخل بس معه لان واضح ان اييي
يعني الازمه الحقيقيه في افريقيا و خلينا
نجمع على ذلك حتى متخصصين في الشؤون
الافريقيه الازمه الحقيقيه هي الامن الامن
هو رقم واحد في المعادله الافريقيه ازاي
يوجد امن لا يوجد سياسه لا يوجد انتخابات
لا يوجد تعليم لا يوجد صحه لا يوجد تنميه
يعني فكره الامن هو المعادله رقم واحد
وبعدين تاتي الاشياء وراءها اذا امنت على
حالك وعلى اموالك وعلى اولادك وعلى عائلتك
وحياتك اظن ان ممكن بعد كده نبتدي نصنف
ونقول اذا كان الارهاب اسلامي ولا مسيحي
ولا شكله ايه لكن خليني دلوقت انا باتكلم
عن الاستراتيجيه الفرنسيه اللي احنا خرجنا
من اطار الحديث عنها للعوده لها مره اخرى
لان انا باتفق معك ان الافرقه رقم واحد في
معادله وجود فرنسا في افريقيا لكن
التغير الحقيقي الحادث الان وانا يعني همم
اؤكد لحضرتك على ده مره ومرارا التغير
الحقيقي الحادث في وجود فرنسا في الدول
افريقيه هو الصراع الاوكراني الروسي وفقا
للمعادلات السياسيه وفكره يعني المنطقه
المنطق يا فندم اتخاذ عوامل المنطق بما
انشئ واذا بما ان هناك اسمع لي الجمله
الاخر يا فندم بما انه هناك تراجع في
الامن الاوروبي اذا هناك سحب للقوات
الفرنسيه بالكامل من كل بقاع الارض وليست
من افريقيا اذا ان هناك تراجع همم من
الناس والادفاع عن اوروبا وامن اوروبا اذن
هناك محاوله لاستعاده هذا النقص شرطيش
عندنا نقص عالي في وجود القوات وبالتالي
هنستعيد عامله الجيش الفرنسي بالتمركز
والتمحور في عملياته وفكره الكثافه
العاليه في العمليات العسكريه للدفاع عن
امن اوروبا وتكون فرنسا في المعادله رقم
واحد رقم اثنين ايا اما يكون لكن لن يكون
هناك اعتماد في المستقبل على الناس دفاعيا
عن اوروبا خلي حضرتك تاخذ فكره العالم
كمذيك كده قطع وركبها مع بعض وشوف ممكن
تطلع بايه من الجمله نهائيه جمله نهائيه
اللي انا عايزه اوصلها للسيادتك والساده
المشاهدين ان هناك افتقار للامن في
افريقيا ان هناك اشكاليه في افريقيا كما
اقل دكتور خطاب ان هناك تراجع عن المواجهه
بين فرنسا وجامعات المسلحه وسيتم
الاستيعاض عنها به الجيوش الوطنيه بعمليه
التدريب والاستخبارات والمعلومات وبالتالي
هيكون هناك دعم فرنسا وتواجد واستراتيجيه
جديده من خلال هذه الامور لكن فكره ان
احنا ناخذ النقاش لازمه اذا كانت الجامعات
الاسلاميه ارهابيه ولا مش اسلاميه
وارهابيه بس يعني
خطر بس خلت اشتراك
الحلفاء الشركاء
الحلفاء الاوروبيين المنظمات الاقليميه هل
هذا يعني ان هناك مقاربه جديده ستظهر بعد
سته اشهر لابد من اشتراك الجميع قبل اتخاذ
اي قرار في التدخل هل هناك ندم على القيام
مثلا بتدخلات عسكري في افريقيا دون
استشاره الاتحاد الافريقي على سبيل المثال
وحصل ذلك في السابق يعني المهم ان يبقى
متطوعين وان تكون هناك اراده من الان الى
ذلك الوقت علينا ان نقر بان
معمر القذافي على ايام حكمه في ليبيا كان
هو الجندرما في منطقه الساحل والان منطقه
الساحل من ضمن الاتمان الذي تدفعها تدفع
اثمان ما بعد الذي حصل في ليبيا اولا رقم
2 فرنسا جربت من خلال ما سمته مجموعه
الدول الساحل الخمسه اي موريتانيا والنيجر
ومالي وتشاد وبوركينا فاسو من ان يكون
لهذه القوه مع بعض القوه الاوروبيه ما دام
عسكري امريكي ولكن هذه التجربه لم تنجح
الان هناك دولتان هما بوركينا فاسو ومالي
تفكران بان التعاون مع مجموعات خاصه
اتفق يمكن ان يكون هو الحل لكن فرنسا لن
تياس هي ستتعامل مع النجر وفيها مركز
اساسي مع تشاد وايضا مع موريتانيا وسيبقى
هناك تعامل مع الاتحاد الاوروبي مع
الاتحاد الافريقي من اجل بلوره خطط جديده
كما قلت خطط جديده لمحاربه الارهاب خطط
جديده لاعطاء الاولويه للقوه الوطنيه
المشكله في تشاد اليوم بعد رحيل ادبي هناك
فراغ هناك مشاكل داخليه النجر وضعها افضل
بعض الشيء لكن لا يمكننا الكلام عن
استقرار فعلي في الساحل واربط افريقيا هذه
مشكله كبرى ولذلك فرنسا ستتاقلم مع ذلك
تحاول بناء استراتيجيه ايضا متحركه
بالتعاون مع مجموعه الدول الساحل والصحراء
مع مجموعه الدول غرب افريقيا مع الاتحاد
الافريقي بالطبع والاتحاد الاوروبي واحلف
شمال الاط حتى هذه الحرب ضد الارهاب تغيرت
اليوم مع الذي حصل في اوكرانيا وهنا اؤكد
على كلام الدكتوره هبه هناك تحول في
الاولويات العالميه هناك متغيرات جيوس
سياسيه حاده هناك اولويه للامن الاوروبي
بالطبع لكن في الماضي عندما تحررت فرنسا
من النازيه اعتمدت كثيرا على شمال افريقيا
وعلى غرب افريقيا لا يمكن لفرنسا ابدا
اهمال هذا البعد الافريقي طيب بقى هناك
مراجعات على ما يبدو بالنسبه للسياسه
الفرنسيه في افريقيا وسياسه العسكريه
عموما ولكن ماذا عن المراجعات من الجانب
الاخر هل هناك استعداد لمراجعات من قبل
مالي على سبيل المثال
نعم هناك يعني المراجعات حتى يعني يكرر
كلامك والكلمه التي استخدمتها هناك
مراجعات ليس فقط في مالي ولكن في كل يعني
دول افريقيا ساحل والصحراء يعني هناك الان
جيل جديد هذا الجميل متعطش جدا الى
السياده السياده الوطنيه السياده العسكريه
السياده الماليه السياده الثقافيه السياده
حتى اللغويه
يعني فاخذنا شو هو الموضوع
هناك طبعا ولكن انا اريد ان القضيه يعني
واضحه بالنسبه لي همم قضيه روسيا
واوكرانيا
لصاحب القوات العسكريه الفرنسيه الله
بوليود همم نجيء نجما يكون عن المتفقين
القوات العسكريه انت مش هتترك هبه خالص
ههه
هي نجحت في بدايه عمليه السربل عام 2013
ميلادي هي نجحت في ذلك وبعد ذلك يعني فشلت
فلان امام المكروه البارحه من صاحب القوات
الفرنسيه في غبون سته اشهر بالنسبه يعني
نتيجه فشل هذا الوجود العسكري الفرنسي
طبعا ينسى مقابته همم يبقى فرنسا احب
فرنسا وثقافتها ونحن فرنسيين وماليين
وتونسيين ههه
همم
القديمه هي الاستراتيجيه الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه
سته اشهر ستكون هناك خطه جديده وهذه الخطه
ستكون جاهزه ما هو محتوى هذه الخطه وما هي
اهداف هذه الخطه كيف تستطيع فرنسا
عند الثقه في الراي والاولاد
ما معلومات ما ما معلومات حضرتك عن
استراتيجيه مكرون حضرتك تكررت الكلمه
كثيرا يعني ما هي الادوات او المعلومات
التي صرح بها مكرونه حضرتك استمعت اليها
وبالتالي بتقر ان ان مش الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هي السبب المباشر
التحدث عن افريقيا مباشره هل تحدث
ان فشل استراتيجيه اتخذها مكر نفسه يعني
تفاصيل الاستراتيجيه يا فندم الافريقي
وثقافه وسياسه
هو تحدث عن العمليات
العسل هل حضرتك كمتخصص تعلم ان العمليات
العسكريه في افريقيا تحتاج لعمليات عسكريه
عاليه الكثافه مواجهه الجامعات المسلحه
وملاحقتها في الصحراء تحتاج عمليات عسكريه
البند الثاني تحدث عن يا افندم
تحدث عن السياسه
النوويه الفرنسيه
للسلاح النووي الفرنسي يبقى موضوع
بنقاش انا عيدكم بنقاش في باماكو حول هذا
الموضوع وعلى المباشر والشكر في الختان من
القاهره الى بشبيشي استاذ دراسات
الافريقيه في جامعه القاهره شكرا باريس في
خطر ابو دياب استاذ العلاقات الدوليه
وايضا دم محمد بكوري وباحث في شؤون
الافريقيه والاجتماعيه شكرا لفريق
البرنامج امسيه مريحه للجميع
[موسيقى]